muchas gracias a los organizadores y
también a todos vosotros por estar aquí
hoy mi objetivo es tratar de explicaros
lo que las células madre pueden y
también lo que mi opinión no pueden
hacer por nosotros
para intentar explicaros lo que hacemos
en mi laboratorio básicamente tratamos
de responder una pregunta que muchos
otros científicos se han planteado antes
básicamente lo que tratamos de entender
es cómo se puede formar un cuerpo humano
completo a partir de una única célula
que resulta de la fecundación del óvulo
por parte del espermatozoide esta
primera célula que surge tras la
fecundación es lo que vemos en el largo
científico el cigoto
y básicamente una vez que se forma este
cigoto comienza a dividirse a
multiplicarse ya generar un número cada
vez mayor de células casi
simultáneamente a medida que estas
células se van dividiendo también
comienzan a ser capaces de transformarse
y dar lugar a otros tipos celulares a
través de un proceso que denominamos
diferenciación celular estos procesos de
multiplicación y diferenciación celular
ocurren simultáneamente durante la
formación primero del embrión y luego
del feto y esto es lo que al final
permite que se formen y aparezcan todos
los órganos y tejidos que forman nuestro
cuerpo y que en conjunto suman más de 30
billones con b de células de más de 200
tipos diferentes y esto insisto se
consigue a partir de una única célula
del cigoto y en apenas 9 meses que es lo
que dura la gestación en humanos lo cual
creo que estaréis de acuerdo conmigo es
algo realmente prodigioso en parte la
capacidad para generar toda esta
complejidad celular que os acabo de
explicar reside en unas células que
aparecen muy pronto durante el
desarrollo embrionario
una vez que se forma el cigoto como se
explicaba comienza a dividirse al cabo
de unas pocas divisiones da lugar a una
estructura embrionaria que llamamos
blastocisto pues bien en éste
blastocisto existen unos pocos cientos
de células todas ellas similares entre
sí y con una propiedad realmente única y
especial que denominamos pluripotencia y
que básicamente lo que hace es que
permite a estas células transformarse y
dar lugar a cualquiera de las células
que existen en nuestro cuerpo por
ejemplo las neuronas de nuestro cerebro
las células de nuestros músculos de
nuestros huesos o las células que
existen en la sangre
debido a esta propiedad de su
pluripotencia las células del
blastocisto atrajeron pues la atención
de los científicos y hace ya varias
décadas algunos científicos lo que
consiguieron fue aislar las células del
blastocisto de embriones humanos y
mantenerlas vivas en el laboratorio para
ello lo que se hace básicamente como
digo es aislar células de embriones
humanos en unos recipientes de plástico
de vidrio que llamamos placas de cultivo
y luego para mantener a estas células
vivas se les añade una especie vamos a
decir de sopa nutritiva de comida para
células y con esto conseguimos sobre
todo dos objetivos en primer lugar como
digo que se mantengan vivas las células
y que mantengan esa propiedad de su
pluripotencia pero además también lo que
conseguimos es que se vuelvan inmortales
y que se mantengan dividiéndose
indefinidamente y manteniendo su
pluripotencia
estas células aisladas originalmente de
las trocitos de embriones humanos y que
luego podemos estudiar y mantener
indefinidamente en el laboratorio es lo
que llamamos células madre embrionarias
y tienen como se acabo de explicar dos
propiedades fundamentales su
inmortalidad y su pluripotencia debido a
estas dos propiedades las células madre
han atraído desde hace mucho tiempo la
atención de los científicos y ya que
siempre se ha pensado que podrían tener
un gran potencial médico y terapéutico
sin embargo durante muchos años la
investigación con células madres se vio
frenada por cuestiones de tipo ético ya
que como se acabo de explicar para poder
obtener estas células es necesario usar
y destruir embriones humanos en los
próximos minutos os explicaré en primer
lugar cómo estas barreras éticas se han
conseguido eliminar prácticamente en los
últimos años y después os explicaré
cuáles son en mi opinión las principales
aplicaciones de este tipo de
investigación con células madre
pero antes de esto me gustaría
explicaros mejor en qué consiste la
pluripotencia ya que como os he dicho
esta es una propiedad fundamental y
esencial de estas células y creo que es
importante entenderlo para luego
apreciar mejor lo que estas células
pueden hacer por nosotros y para
explicar en qué consiste la
pluripotencia me gustaría usar una
analogía que en su día usó un científico
un biólogo de desarrollo muy famoso
conrad waddington en esta analogía
conrad waddington represento a las
células madre como unas bolas o canicas
que gracias a su pluripotencia estaba en
lo alto de una montaña
como os acabo de explicar las células
madre cuando comienza el desarrollo
comienzan a transformarse y dar lugar a
todas las células que existen en nuestro
cuerpo pues bien en nuestra analogía
esto equivaldría con que las células
madre están en lo alto de una de la
montaña y comienzan a descender por
diferentes caminos o rutas que acaban en
los diferentes valles que existen en
esta montaña y cada uno de los cuales
equivaldría a los diferentes tipos de
célula que existen en nuestro cuerpo
en nuestra analogía esto equivaldría a
que la célula madre comienza a descender
por la montaña pase a través de
diferentes rutas o caminos que al final
acaban en cada uno de los valles que
equivaldrían a cada uno de los tipos
celulares de nuestro cuerpo lo que los
científicos hemos conseguido en el
laboratorio es en cierto modo mantener a
las células en lo alto de la montaña que
mantenga su pluripotencia mientras así
nosotros lo queramos y que además
también lo que hemos conseguido es que
cuando nosotros no deseemos comiencen a
descender por la montaña y además lo
hagan por la ruta que nosotros queramos
para así poder transformarlas en el tipo
de célula que nos interese por ejemplo
en neuronas de nuestro cerebro
debido a esta pluripotencia y también a
su inmortalidad las células madre como
os decía han despertado siempre un gran
interés ya que se ha pensado siempre que
podrían tener muchas aplicaciones
médicas y de terapia sin embargo en
muchos países la investigación con
células madre se vio frenada por
cuestiones de tipo ético ya que en
muchos países incluso por motivos
científicos está prohibido o muy
restringido el uso de embriones humanos
sin embargo estas barreras éticas se
consiguieron eliminar casi en su
totalidad hace ya más de diez años
cuando un científico japonés premio
nobel de medicina llamado shinya
yamanaka consiguió tener células madre a
partir de pequeñas muestras de tejido
adulto
estas células madre que podemos obtener
a partir de muestras de tejido adulto es
lo que denominamos células madre
pluripotentes inducidas o células y psc
debido a sus siglas en inglés y estas
células tienen realmente exactamente las
mismas propiedades que las células madre
embrionarias que os comentaba que se
derivan de embriones humanos ya que
también son pluripotentes inmortales la
aparición de estas células madre
inducidas ha representado un hito
histórico en la investigación con este
tipo de células ya que por primera vez
podemos obtener estas células sin usar
embriones marx sino simplemente como os
decía una pequeña muestra del tejido que
puede ser una muestra de piel una
muestra de sangre o incluso una muestra
de orina
gracias a la aparición de este tipo de
células durante los últimos años hemos
sido testigos de avances increíbles en
la investigación con células madre que
han cambiado de forma drástica la forma
en la que hoy en día podemos entender e
incluso curar determinadas enfermedades
humanas
a un nivel de investigación básica una
de las principales aplicaciones de la
investigación con células madre es
tratar de entender mejor el desarrollo
embrionario en humanos hasta hace poco
nuestro conocimiento del desarrollo
embrionario en humanos era de hecho
bastante limitado y estaba sobre todo
basado en estudiar embriones que
obteníamos de modelos animales como
pueden ser el ratón el pez cebra la rana
etcétera sin embargo las células madres
gracias a su pluripotencia ya su
mortalidad nos permiten en cierto modo
ser capaces de recapitular el desarrollo
embrionario en un tubo de ensayo en el
laboratorio y sin tener que usar ningún
tipo de embrión
si bien esto es así también hay que
reconocer que nuestra capacidad actual
de generar los diferentes tipos de
células sobre todo los diferentes
órganos que existen un embrión real a
partir del células madre es aún
imperfecta e incompleta pero en este
sentido también ha habido grandes
avances durante los últimos dos o tres
años y en la actualidad tenemos
estrategias que nos permiten no ya
simplemente a partir de las madres
obtener otro tipo de célula por ejemplo
insisto las neuronas de nuestro cerebro
sino que han surgido estrategias por las
cuales estas células madres se pueden
transformar en pequeños órganos que
denominamos órgano jdd es que se
asemejan cada vez más a los órganos que
existen en el embrión incluso en un
individuo adulto por ejemplo en los
últimos años han surgido estrategias con
las cuales a partir de células madre
podemos obtener en pequeños órganos que
se asemejan a un cerebro a un páncreas o
intestino
estos avances en nuestra capacidad de
transformar o de generar prácticamente
lo que queramos a partir de las células
madre junto con la aparición de las
células madre inducidas han cambiado
también de forma drástica la forma en la
que podemos tratar de entender las
enfermedades humanas por ejemplo los
llamados defectos de nacimiento estos
defectos de nacimiento en muchos casos
vienen causados por fallos genéticos y
alteraciones genéticas que producen
fallos durante el proceso de desarrollo
embrionario y que acaban causando que
aparezcan defectos en estos pacientes
una vez que nacen
ya que los fallos o las causas de esta
enfermedad ocurren durante el desarrollo
embrionario siempre han sido muy
difíciles de estudiar en muchos casos
son incurables y en muchos casos las
causas los motivos exactos que provocan
estas enfermedades son desconocidas sin
embargo con las células madre inducidas
ha surgido una nueva forma de entender o
de tratar de entender estas enfermedades
por ejemplo en unos estos pacientes en
las cuales hay alteraciones genéticas
que causan la enfermedad lo que podemos
hacer es tomar una pequeña muestra de
piel y en estas células de la piel
van a estar esos fallos genéticos que
provocan esta enfermedad
a continuación estas células de la piel
las podemos transformar en células madre
que van a seguir teniendo esta
alteración y por último gracias a su
pluripotencia estas células madres lo
que nos van a permitir es tratar de
recapitular el desarrollo embrionario de
este paciente cuando era un embrión
todavía dentro de su madre y tratar de
observar y también de entender qué fallo
durante ese proceso que acabó que acabó
con provocando la aparición de sus
defectos una vez que estos pacientes
nacen
basándonos en una idea similar de los
últimos años han surgido estrategias que
nos permiten no ya solo tratar de
entender sino incluso de tratar algunas
de estas enfermedades por ejemplo
existen enfermedades donde de nuevo
alteraciones genéticas pueden provocar
daños en tejidos como por ejemplo puede
ser la retina de nuestros ojos que
pueden provocar ceguera en este caso una
posible estrategia sería de nuevo
obtener células de la piel de estos
pacientes donde van a estar presentes
estas alteraciones genéticas que luego
podemos transformar en estas células
madre y el truco importante aquí es que
luego actualmente han surgido lo que
llamamos herramientas de ingeniería
genética que básicamente lo que nos
permiten es reparar estos fallos y
obtener células madre sanas
una vez que tenemos estas células madres
sanas gracias a su pluripotencia las
podemos transformar en el tipo celular
que a nosotros nos interese por ejemplo
en células de la retina sanas sin ningún
tipo de alteración genética estas
células de la retina
ahora las podemos transportar de vuelta
en el ojo del paciente reparar su retina
y que puedan recuperar
quizás para alguno de vosotros esto que
os acabo de comentar
suele casi a ciencia ficción pero de
hecho en algunos países como japón donde
la investigación con células madre está
más avanzada y sobre todo más aceptada
socialmente es una estrategia de terapia
celular que ya se está usando de hecho
es cada vez más habitual encontrar en la
prensa titulares como los que os muestro
en la imagen que claramente ilustran que
la terapia celular basada en sus células
madre es una estrategia real que se está
usando para curar enfermedades que hasta
hace poco se consideraban realmente
incurables
este tipo de noticias por supuesto
pueden crear euforia y optimismo pero a
la vez hay que ser cauto porque la
investigación con células madre todavía
tiene sus riesgos por ejemplo como os
comentaba nuestra capacidad de
transformar estas células madre en
cualquier tipo de célula o tejido que
queramos es a una imperfecta también si
usamos las células madre para
trasplantes aún existen riesgos por
ejemplo sabemos de casos donde han
ocurrido respuestas inmunes indeseadas
también mientras mantenemos a estas
células madre en el laboratorio puede
que acumulen alteraciones genéticas y si
luego usamos estas células para
trasplante en cierto modo les vamos a
pasar estas alteraciones genéticas a
estos pacientes por último una propiedad
muy importante como os decía de las
células madre es un mortalidad y esta es
una propiedad que comparten con las
células del cáncer por tanto si usamos
células madre para trasplantes y no
están perfectamente diferenciadas y
retienen parte de su inmortalidad lo que
podría pasar es que estas células
provoquen la aparición de tumores en
nuestros pacientes que reciben este tipo
de trasplantes
en cualquier caso creo que existen
motivos claros para el optimismo ya que
estos riesgos se están minimizando cada
vez son menores y por tanto creo que no
es descabellado pensar que en unos años
las terapias basadas en el uso de
células madres se puedan usar para curar
un número cada vez mayor de enfermedades
esto justo junto con otros avances
médicos creo que lo que puede hacer es
que en unos años veamos como la terapia
basada en células madre puede ayudar a
expandir nuestra esperanza de vida
actual
y dicho todo esto me gustaría que entre
todos imaginemos que efectivamente en
unos años estos riesgos y problemas que
yo os he contado que aún existen se van
a solucionar insisto creo que esto no es
descabellado pues algo que la ciencia
nos demuestra una y otra vez es que lo
que hoy nos parece ciencia ficción en
unos años puede convertirse en una
realidad pues bien si imaginamos que
estos problemas se solucionan creo que
lo que deberíamos realmente plantearnos
es cuáles deben ser los principales
objetivos de la investigación con
células madre en mi opinión y ahora me
gustaría hablar no como un científico
sino como un ciudadano más en mi opinión
creo que el objetivo no debería ser
expandir nuestra esperanza de vida de
una forma dramática sino sobre todo
mejorar la calidad de la misma dicho de
otra forma creo que el objetivo no debe
ser que alcancemos la inmortalidad
ni siquiera quizás que expandamos mucho
más nuestra esperanza de vida actual al
menos en los países avanzados
ya que por diferentes motivos creo que
esto sería insostenible o egoísta si
pensamos en los recursos limitados de
nuestro planeta o si también pensamos un
poco en las siguientes generaciones en
resumen que aunque las células sean
células madres son inmortales nosotros
no lo somos y al menos en mi opinión
tampoco creo que debamos aspirar a serlo
en cualquier caso este tipo de
cuestiones son problemáticas y bastante
personales y tampoco creo que las
debamos dejar únicamente en manos de los
científicos pues a nosotros para lo que
se nos ha entrenado es para intentar
descifrar los secretos de la naturaleza
no para resolver cuestiones de tipo
ético o moral por tanto en mi opinión el
futuro de la investigación sobre células
madre es un tema que debería involucrar
a toda la sociedad en su conjunto y
quizás la labor de los científicos
debería ser sobre todo tratar de
explicar estos temas de una forma
sencilla pero rigurosa
para acercarlo lo más posible a toda la
gente
dicho esto me gustaría terminar mi
charla simplemente planteando varias
preguntas dejarlas abiertas en el aire y
de nuevo recordaros que lo que oí en la
investigación con células madre nos
parece una quimera creo que en unos años
en muchos casos se puede convertir una
realidad por tanto creo que todos nos
deberíamos plantear algunas de las
preguntas que os enseño aquí por ejemplo
deberíamos pensar seriamente acerca de
cuáles deben ser los límites éticos de
la investigación con células madre
igualmente deberíamos pensar acerca de
cuáles deben ser los principales
objetivos de este tipo de investigación
y de forma más general creo que
deberíamos plantearnos si el ser humano
debe o no aspirar a la mortalidad muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]